from the twitter account dorian is not
gray which frankly applies to tom brady
on multiple levels how much of tommy's
future in tampa bay has to do with the
length of their playoff run do you think
he'll be back after a first round exit
or a super bowl win is there a scenario
where you see that he doesn't return in
2021 look i it's been made clear to me
and the talk around the the league is is
uh obvious on this point
the buccaneers want brady back next year
more than anything else they want him
back because they intend to have a full
stadium next year and they want to get
the financial windfall of having tom
brady and the farther they go in the
playoffs the greater the urgency to get
him back next year because it's just a
taste of what 2021 can be even if they
win the super bowl they could try to win
two in a row with tom brady so
they want him back no matter what and
and shireen i think the improvements
they've made in recent weeks i fault
them
for not properly managing expectations
in august september october and into
november since the bye week though
they've been very good and i think as we
all kind of decided maybe they're not
going to be that good this year that
lowered the expectations organically and
now
they're look they're i think one of the
most dangerous teams in the nfc playoff
field
i think he's going to be back no matter
what next year he he looks great he's
going to be 44 in august and he hasn't
lost a thing yet and he wants to prove
to himself and to all of us that he can
keep playing deep into his 40s i think
we have to start thinking about him
ripping up the expected deadline of the
the season that would happen when he
turns 45 which would be 2022 i think he
may play longer than that so i don't
know how much
and i don't think much
of what happens in the playoffs is going
to get him to not come back even if they
win the super bowl i don't see him
walking away because it's more about
it's about more at this point than
winning super bowls it's about proving
how far he can push it into the future
not only do they want him back mike
which we know that because as you said
this is about money making money it's a
money-making business and they didn't
get the the windfall from that from
having the full stadiums we know how
much they've struggled putting people in
the seats and all the jerseys they sold
this year all those sorts of things they
absolutely want him back and i think
that tom brady wants to come back i
think he likes living there i think he
likes working with bruce arians this is
despite the sometimes criticism and i
think he thinks he can win there with
the weapons that he had he's never had
those kind of weapons at new england
even the randy moss here i don't think
he had that group of weapons that he has
now he feels like he can win in a second
year he certainly feels like he can get
that done the last four games he's been
terrific 12 touchdowns one interception
and i think we've all kind of ignored it
but this just again speaks to the
greatness of tom brady he's been great
this season mike if they'd won those
saints games we'd probably have him in
the mvp conversation
and just think of how much better he'll
be if he has a full off-season to
prepare and knows the offense even
better and knows the personnel even
better that was what slowed them down
out of the gates it's not slowing them
down now and again i think they're going
to be incredibly dangerous in january
one more quick one from sean alves shire
do you think the dolphins will consider
using the third overall pick on a
quarterback after what they've seen from
two of this season i don't know why you
wouldn't evaluate fully evaluate and if
it takes you that way so be it the
cardinals did it with josh rosen a
couple of years ago if you come to the
conclusion you can get a better
quarterback with that third overall pick
you deal with it you make the pick and
you move on from two if that's what you
have to do i'm concerned that they
picked the wrong guy if i was a dolphins
fan it would be causing me
significant angst and and consternation
right now that we could have had justin
herbert and we didn't take him
well the problem is you feel like trevor
lawrence and justin fields are going to
be gone one and two whatever order it is
but they're both going to be off the off
the board for number three and then
you're talking about you know other guys
like byu's uh zach wilson and trey lance
from north dakota state and guys like
that maybe they get a quarterback later
in the first round with that second pick
mike rather than the rather than that
number three overall pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports